[Applause]
Marko's lazada silva wears who's out on
his back number seven Paul Dini ba you
are paid to make those have a place
they'll understand they're right okay so
for all the young guys out there
listening the NBA is paying you to make
those type of plays they're not
surprised when you do it all so French
on the defense and finish on those lob
to win the point guard hits you that's
what you're looking for you 7-foot is
these days haze drizzle without the ball
and as fellow rookie Alexander Walker
finds him with a bullet pass for the
Duncan Alexander Walker gets it right
back for some early in the game prior
the Boston Celtics had Kara Lawson
definitely that was the show stopped
once by the Bulls here's the replay as
Mychal Mulder steps over outside the
line so he's in legal guarding position
everything every time you say that and
that reminds me I was born in 1963 seen
in his family you can sign you look at
Hayes look at our day back not bad
you guys look at these kids they are
free Kathleen he can't finish we have
seen that already
rookie to rookie starting Jackson hey it
looked like a kid that played in college
and get to the NBA a reverse lob Hayes
dunked so far this time he does it with
a quick mask you have to am a basket how
do you let him get high that's another
good question because we saw him earlier
go baseline which is unusual considering
how many guys on the floor fighting for
roster spots in positions there's
another Doug France who's a player or
two that stood out to you so far today
John uhrin it's summer like who's a guy
we look at you say okay you know what I
can see where this piece might fit it
have some rumors from my inside people
there that something could be coming but
I who knows we go on a three or four
game winning food we just can't play you
guys did not end well Jana Smith jr. the
New York Knicks watching courtside Hayes
Flushing at home will see the New York
Knicks meanwhile Jackson Hayes for the
pelicans he came into the game one
spores in summer league averaging 28
earth quarter went fast with me and
George arguing with each other an
entertaining 10 minutes as I thought
Jackson haze something every game comes
out of nowhere here - you might want to
put a body on Jackson hate start of the
fourth quarter
Jackson Hayes with the putback bucket
else caught the 25 year old from Trenton
New Jersey when I did a few years ago
holy cow Jackson Hayes and his viral
string of dunks his head on this play he
just rained it full speed the bucket on
one end and fearless attacking the glass
there's a lot to like about Jackson
Hayes man he is a playing god I've never
heard that off the court he's out of the
issues but competition can be an issue
look at that I can't believe he did that
a reverse alley by Jackson Hayes they
got him with the eighth pick it's gonna
be coached by Andrew gays and the
competitions Jackson Hayes just practice
last October 22nd don't ask me why I
remember and when I did my first
reaction was when I saw this kid was
he's the best prospect in the big 12 now
Jared Culver certainly what's up you
guys this Taylor Brooks with bleacher
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more video content what's up you
guys this Taylor Brooks with bleacher
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more video content